chi non sente la musica ora si sente
[Musica]
come si chiamasse gioco di micologo il
caso bello così fa youtubers smash
allora ci sono due youtuber grazie hanno
degli iscritti e tu devi dire che ne so
pietro fuori j chiari iscritti o vi
avesse bullismo e devi mettere pietro
per te grazie a pietà allora io ti aver
smesso giocato un milione di una patch
numerosi gli italiani messi a confronto
chiaro iscritti tra i due la smettiamo
allora vai gioca in italia c'è anche
globale quale youtube come si chiami
skill a non è uno youtubers che ora è un
crash sbagliava mai cosa centra il come
dischi le province già tutti caciotti
per sammarco emis killa
il gioco perché abbiamo scelto sta roba
tra tutti i giochi piceno riprova va
bene a devi arrivare al di fare un
punteggio
qual è la youtuber cube iscritti degli
who magico izzard tv show non ne ho mai
non si visionano ai vigili non siamo
capaci a questo giocatore perché non
riesco a giocare per giocare come
dovesse cessare abilitare javascript per
un cervello ma come si fa ad avere un
cervello e in questo per dire che
riguarda quanti come possiamo averne
giocatore singolo poi avete per come
iscritto e andiamo ravi su youtube siamo
sfilati prossimo suite bio design di
tutorial e altri che invece sono
controcorrente
vai a vedere continuamente avevo fatto
bene cioè come lo ritroviamo iscritti
bello figo michele bravi che a livello
canoro si equivale del mugello fi ma
scherzi ma porca vacca detto vuoi dire
brava capitolo mai prima era di tommy
nel mazzo olio todi grazie io son ivan
direction e mazen
no ero mai grande piero mobili abbiamo
giocato solo io craxi che torni ci ha
fatto guadagnare due punti e basta
dai destra è chiamato animation gli
amateur imation è fighissimo perché
trasmette degli anni e che facciano un
botto e steiner stripe sicuramente 600
bilancio amaro però mi piace un botto
prossimo federgioco tv sarà il lapidario
ma non so mi chiuse
beh mica scherzi di coppia o krav maga
training
ma cosa fa questa parti marziali calzini
coppia ci teniamo ben altri centri non
lo so penso di primo secondo me ha di
meno ma perché il mio studi ma lasciando
abbiamo combattimenti di coppia ed anche
se non fate gli iscritti porca [ __ ]
quelli ricercati dio smith e smith smith
e anche richard h v pina de la tana è
una pastiglia sempre il fastidio che ti
viene con al derby allerton io mi fido
di finire conosciuta di youtube e la
catena livio fastidio melina sono 167
prossima ragazze gigi calisti non so chi
cazzo si sa però il cctc di capanne di
più perché cazzo sun nel 241 ma poi giro
su schemi gc nei medi di un milione
grande gigi cosa fai video di portieri
fallito di portieri tissimo ma questa è
quella tipo festa mesta non ha mai and
dragons tech no mk di gestione che mi
fido di gesù manuel emotive dei kdg
dragster papa ebrei erano state fatti
crescere le tette per sotto sia un
maschio francesco sole o infinito il
cancello milito e quello li divide ore
siamo infine non è infinito fa
l'attaccante caldo ed avrà infiniti
discreti di concedesse forzano youtuber
prossimo spa deejay tv svesta play stein
allora io so che tu fai video belli
perché lo so perché mai però perche'per
ci pensi se ci pensi se invece le armi
chiara di dio che tua idea di merda
prossimo
ora records al 4 esatto could you be to
be traumi chiude a chico record record
ad arrivare a 10 da polsi blog
adrian spingerà porta volta che esce tv
con descrittiva quel
tipo è una ragazza di 20 anni come cavia
ma se va bene allora doubles i blog
[Musica]
l'ansia o meno 4 in un quadro madonna
prossimo nic
gabo così avrà subito mattino ma domanda
che vi siano così tanti iscritti
no è un po meno ma che cazzo di date che
si scriva sinti che facciamo da sector
giallo zattera letta giallozafferano
mica niguarda che la cucina mila pasti
non mi dicono mesi fanno dice sempre una
bella pasta al giallo grande giallo che
l'anno prossimo se le malattie che
sembrano attenzione prossimo
amedeo preziosi della sera se non potrà
pattinare la poca entra nelle preziosi
cazzo è riconosciamo tutti e due non lo
sappiamo ha date ma ti ha fatto milione
l'altro giorno innanzitutto complimenti
daniele io ti seguo da quando nave di
5.000 non è uno scherzo e ct segue da
quando io non ne avevo zero nel senso
che vanno fatti 4 milioni
vieni andiamo se come daniele io ti amo
non ho capito che da da mediano quanti
iscritti a chi abbonati nuove elezioni
basta mettere io mi sono sempre che sei
stata una delle ragioni per le quali ho
iniziato a fare i video su youtube
io credo in te daniele vorrebbe vedere
[Applauso]
[Musica]
daniele perché date iscritti a questo
cristiano subito niente più persone
porca 80 anni porino ma almeno vediamo
un po più di iscritti di preziosi
arrivare i pro liberiamoci da e moccia
bastano ma perché non leggi anche
l'altro figlio di prova e giacca
ok ma lei gigi massa questo gennaio 10
13 ecco che si può giocare un vecchio
uomo gv scampoli scuole non è capo di
square
secondo o terzo quarto quinto canale sul
secondo canale cane secco no era giorno
di tutta la [ __ ] salmo o no clio clio
nicchia ha minato salme crew topi questo
lo so perché il make up stage azzeccano
insieme gli autogol menava goudron
svegliano come se in cai in italia serie
a dai gli italiani non sono non sono
neanche coerenti
il calcio solo mangiano a colazione e
api iscritti film eclipse ma com'è
possibile coccole sonore margin call e
sonoro zhenkov colesanti faccio le
coccole e uno nel mentre a sea lion tra
gli white vip e non aver gay va bene gay
va dai sei make up o fim eclipse coppe
scottex scottex spulcia 3.000 a quello
bene ma non benissimo
sborsi allora film cerco dei nostri 500
600 mila atti mattina saro c300 neanche
questi docenti costosa freemax mamma via
toti relative latino fatti vi aspetta i
due bomber eto'o come laceranti mi pare
mi piaci mentono ste cose alla fine i
due bomber fermo azzeccando m guy wilks
factor
rp de galinhas che preme reali o mi
incazzo è già santo sono sei stanco di
vedere che non rende meno anzi penso ci
sia gente che faccia 40 di fila si
abbiano perché romana controllate siamo
persone oneste cat
mammamia galica di claudia la prima
volta richiamo perché vai infinito
federica volte 280 circa sempre a
collaborare kagami cos'è un calcolatore
a del banco de show the show the show
giovanni greco disney joe nick e giochi
mamma mia donna alice a me è ok è vero
avete preziosi vorrebbe rosolini
meraviglia di meraviglie mai andiamo più
16 cosa ma come si è arrivati a 16 e poi
non hanno più continuato perché l'acqua
non superiore pd 16 ago non si priva di
più di sedici perché pari a 16 punti
presentare
che sfiga ma guarda accesso la sola non
ho capito faccio cliccato due volte
cazzola vedeva ben così siamo forti
sappiamo sappiamo di essere imbattuti da
lui però ragazzi io spero che il video
vi sia piaciuto volevamo fare questa
roba per fare per dare sfogo alla nostra
ignoranza su youtube italia perché io
veramente non segue una sexy bar di di
menti però poi abbiamo un viaggio tra
tutti gli insulti ci siamo beccati dai
suddetti youtuber vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi non sappiamo un cazzo di youtube
italia ma io sono quello che avevate
iscritti e questa cosa qua e là tattoo
anche con donna ma io sono una persona
di 28 centri calcio alla persona
eccentrica ciao ragazzi cosa sicuramente
mi piace anche sociali descrizione senza
tagli ai miei calzini
ma questi non li lava da giorni ha detto
ht tutti questi di schede non ci vediamo
al prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]